- If I ran Nintendo today, I'd
probably put out 5,000 pieces
of creative content
starring Zelda and Mario
and build up the IP and make
sure all those characters
and all those visions would be winning
on TikTok, Instagram, YouTube.
I would just produce at scale.
This has now become
singularly a making game.
Make.
Make, make, make.
(yells)
You got your perspective.
(engine whirring)
(audience cheers)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(jazzy music)
- [Male Audience Member] If
you were to give a percentage
of your work, life and home-life
balance, what would it be?
Do you think the balance is important
to being successful in
your overall day to day?
- Yes.
But I also think that
balance ebbs and flows.
So, I'm probably spending
more time on my life
right now than ever.
I mean, look.
People look at things funny.
Between being fully, all-in on weekends,
between five other weeks of
vacation during the year,
you're already at a place
where you're talking about
you only work 225, of the 360,
you know like, people are very funny
about how they think
about work-life balance.
I think that for me,
somebody who enjoys work,
between those vacations and weekends,
and now my kids are
getting older so now it is,
go to a soccer match in
the middle of the day
which is super foreign to me.
I used to be nine a.m.,
midnight, every minute, boom.
So, but again I think it's similar
to not judging myself that
somebody's upset this morning.
You can only do your best.
And I think one of the biggest
weaknesses in our society
is that people beat themselves
up at every, single second
instead of looking at
it in a year's worth,
or a life's work, or at
least a month's work.
And so I think balance is important,
I also think everybody
here has different balance.
Some people think nine
to five is balanced.
I would hate my life if
I worked nine to five.
It's just too much downtime for me.
I enjoy what I do too much.
So you get to define balance.
You get to judge yourself.
And people literally take
the opinions of their parents
and friends into how they
parent or work-life balance.
That is so laughable.
Too much peer pressure.
Too much judgment.
(crunches)
- [Male Audience Member] So in terms
of where you see advertising,
and maybe not even just digital,
where would you see advertise
going in five, 10 years?
- I have no idea.
A hypothesis I have, definitely,
is Voice is gonna be a player.
I definitely believe
that the new interface
that's brewing is Voice and
its impact will be as large
as the mobile device when at scale.
15, 17 years from now.
I'm not, you know I get a lot of credit
because of the way I invested
and all the documentation
of being right a lot.
But what I try to remind people is,
when I was saying those things,
it had already happened.
I'm not predicting TikTok,
it has 1.5 billion downloads.
The fuck kind of guess is that?
(audience laughs)
It's just that people love
to say "no" about today.
Let alone the future.
I'm not worried about AR,
Blockchain, you know, ML, VR.
All that's coming.
I'm watching all of it.
But no real people use it yet.
And so people love to jump the gun
on technology advancements
ahead of the consumer behavior.
I am blindly a day trader of this second.
Before I worry about how to
get my AR capabilities down,
why not maximize the shit out of today?
Right this second?
LinkedIn, TikTok, Instagram,
grossly under-priced.
- And advertising's always been
the leading edge of culture.
So AR has to, and VR has to
begin to weave its way in,
and as advertising agencies,
do we have to be at the forefront on that?
- In a practical way.
The reason I've been able to do that
is 'cause I'm willing to make less money.
Not super complicated, back to CFO.
CFO walks in says,
"I want to shut down
the Voice department."
I'm like, "Then shut
down the whole company."
He's like, "But it's not profitable."
I'm like, "I'm aware."
That's the punchline.
The reason most agencies
aren't able to pull it off
is because they don't want to
give up the margin that year.
You're not gonna have clients
often pay to subsidize,
those new advancements.
But I think the key is to
not be too far in advance.
So we do have people
flirting with AR and VR
and things of that nature,
but it is flirting.
Because it's just not close.
I don't think people
realize how not close VR is.
I don't know a single person
that knows a single person
that spends an hour a
day in a VR environment.
Every person spends seven
hours a day on a phone.
I'm talking about a real delta.
So, yeah.
To me it's the speed in adjusting
to what the consumer's done.
What I'm proud of is,
as soon as Musically
gets bought by TikTok,
they relaunch, stuff starts happening.
Our ability at Vayner to be
a creative on that depart,
in that world within
moments of it becoming real,
that's the strength more than predicting.
It's the speed in which
you can execute in today
versus the variable of
being right about tomorrow.
- [Host] We talked a little bit
before the live stream started
about how you've scaled
your company and just from
a cultural standpoint,
but also from a process standpoint,
from an accountability standpoint.
Could you speak that a little bit?
- Yeah, it's a human game.
You know, from a cultural standpoint,
from a process standpoint,
it's just judging the judgers at my level.
I think people are very naive
on how much the variable
of success is predicated on the CEO.
She or he has a whole lot of say.
They're the judge and the jury.
A CEO is basically the Supreme Court.
It's pretty final.
These are dictatorships.
Obviously there's boards in some companies
that may have a little juice,
but the reality is that
the way we've done it
is by actually caring about it.
It's not super complicated.
I would, we're far more advanced
on culture than process.
I hate process so much that
I don't look at it often
and any time I do look at it,
it look like it's going really poorly
and so then I just cry and go to sleep.
(laughs)
And so.
- You have a Chief Heart Officer.
- We do.
- Do you have a Chief Process Officer?
- We don't.
And I think that there's a couple reasons.
And we won't.
I believe that human beings
that work in companies
are disproportionately
obsessed with process.
And I think the second you
start putting the process
in front of the output you lose
and I think almost every company
puts the process in front of the output.
I'd rather the process
be murky and breakable
than put on a pedestal.
It's a tricky one.
- It is.
- It's a tricky one but if you
listen to what I just said,
what you'll learn is it
will come down to casting.
And if you work on culture
and people aren't political
with each other and jerks,
they'll figure it out much
easier and with less friction
but the reality is most
agencies have too much process
and way too much insecurity in politics
and thus it's slow and clunky and crappy.
- [Female Audience Member]
Are you saying that
data privacy regulations
are ready to handle
a world in which everything is
AI that we do?
- So I think, I think.
I'll answer the second one first.
It's about data privacy
regulations can handle a world
where AI, where every,
single product is smart,
at scale, two decades from now,
which is the assumption or
guess that I have right now.
No, but I think there's a
much bigger conversation
around data privacy that's not being had,
which is, I actually
don't think people care
about the privacy.
I think there's a much more
thoughtful conversation going on
that will eventually play out,
which is, I'm gonna predict
that it's gonna go the other way.
I would prefer that every technology
knew everything about me.
I mean it.
Unless you kill my
children or steal my money,
I prefer you know everything.
This notion of privacy.
What privacy are we
actually talking about?
What websites I went on?
My credit card number?
You give away your credit card
number every day, everywhere.
Target and the IRS have much
bigger breaches than Facebook.
I think there's this
fun narrative right now
to demonize technology
because we don't like being accountable.
The Russians didn't make
you vote for someone.
You did.
(audience laughs)
You decided to believe.
And so this huge lack of
accountability will play out.
So, I'm not.
You know, look.
If somebody is creeped out
that the refrigerator
reordered their milk,
'cause the milk spoke to the frigerator
and it said, "We have one pour left,"
they're more than welcome to not.
I keep reminding people, I'm like,
"Don't have a smart phone."
"Gary this all sucks, it's all terrible."
I'm like, "Delete Facebook."
"I did."
I'm like, "But you're on Instagram."
"Yeah, but I like it."
(audience laughs)
I mean.
Look, I think as an agency
when you think about
the smartification, you're
talking about building.
You're talking about actually being indev.
Which is not a big passion
of mine, ironically.
I don't like building the highways,
I like driving them
better than anybody else.
So I think when you talk
about smartification,
where it's all gonna lead to is brand.
Brand is gonna become
the most important thing
because when you're
ordering on a voice device,
you better say, "Kleenex" not "tissues."
You'd better say "Nike" not "sneakers."
Because then Amazon or Google
are gonna pick for you, right.
Same thing with brand.
Once I put that Pepsi in that fridge,
that fridge is reordering Pepsi,
not me deciding to pick up
Coke at an end cap at Walmart.
So, brand.
It's like I can't yell about it enough.
Look at my own behaviors.
The signature, the sonic branding.
Like this is all branding for me.
All my friends call me
a sucker for giving away
the 270 page deck the other day.
Not me.
I think about brand.
You feel warmer towards me.
I did something nice for you.
People don't get it.
So, that's how I see, I
think privacy's really funny.
I think Europe is a really miss...
Is really misplaying the world.
I think Europe's growing
irrelevance has a lot to do
with the defense they have
around all this stuff.
When Google and Facebook
and all these other companies
don't want to be there,
that's going to be bad, not good.
- [Female Audience Member] How do you,
you're obviously putting
out a lot of content
over so many different platforms,
so my question is how do you
measure the success of that?
Is it based on purely likes
and as we start to see likes going away.
- Likes will go away only
for our insecurities outward,
but we will still see them on the backend.
But keep going, is that?
- [Female Audience Member]
Yeah, so I'm wondering
what is your way of measuring?
- My measurement on success
is far more qualitative
'cause I'm trying to win on brand.
I'm not trying to sell K-Swiss sneakers.
I know that I sold a
thousand pairs yesterday
on this singular, Instagram post,
but that is not where my mind
goes on, is that good or bad.
My mind works this way.
When I went to the airport last week
and a seven year old ran up
to me and asked for a selfie,
I knew TikTok was working.
So for me it's qualitative.
I know something's working
based on reading the comments at scale.
So for me it's much more
the comments themselves.
Not how many comments,
the interpretation of the
intent of the comments.
'Cause I'm building brand,
I'm not worried about how
many likes and shares it gets.
- [Male Audience Member]
So I know that Facebook
has been testing search
apps, quite recently.
I think it was rolled out
last minute to advertisers,
so I was wondering do you envision a day
where the local advertisers
that Facebook becomes
a viable search option
as opposed to Google and Bing?
- I thought so years ago.
But much like I knew Google
Plus wasn't gonna work
'cause it wasn't in Google's DNA,
Facebook has not shown to me
that search is inherently
in their collective DNA.
I'm shocked that Facebook is
not a bigger search player,
given the scale that they had.
Given how great the data could have been.
Not as confident as I used to be.
But that's what's great about everything.
You can reboot anything.
They can hire one great
executive from Google
and she could drive it.
There's a whole lot of interesting data
that I'd love to search
that's public in Facebook
from a search engine standpoint.
But I do think certain
companies have certain DNAs.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- [Male Audience Member] Mmm hmm.
I'd like to (inadequate audio)
- please.
(audience laughs)
- [Male Audience Member] So this is like,
I know what we talked about earlier
and you kind of did answer it but,
Google just released their
cloud gaming platform.
- Yup.
- Google Stadia.
- Do you envision
basically within the next decade,
we're now seeing gaming
ads offered by Google?
- Yes.
Google will absolutely go
into dynamic gaming ads.
They just need to have the
control of the inventory
so they've got to win the IP game
because if they have
to go through Blizzard
or somewhere else, they've got a problem.
Whoever owns the IP wins that game, right.
Otherwise they're gonna
have to pay a huge vig
to the game creator to get in there.
And then by nature, the ad
won't be inherently native
'cause there'll be a friction
between two different companies,
almost like Creative and Media.
So I think Google.
But I think what people forget
is how big these companies are.
Google could buy one of the top
gaming studios in the world.
But yes, I do.
Gaming is.
People are extremely naive
about where gaming is in our society.
East Sports is easily one
of the top three sports
in America in 15 years
with basketball and soccer
being the other two that
have the most upside.
Whereas football is stagnant
even though it's America's passion.
And hockey and baseball
continue to decline.
I mean the five best
baseball players in America
could walk into this office right now,
and 95% of this audience
would not know who they are.
They'd be like, "Those are
some good-looking, buff dudes."
(audience laughs)
But they wouldn't know
that it's Mike Trout.
And he's the best player.
The best.
And when you're in a place where the,
by the way, not only is Mike Trout
the best player in baseball,
he's probably gonna go down
as one of the best players of all time.
And the fact that half the
audience doesn't even know
who that is, is a real
big problem for baseball.
And that, by the way, is a good
lesson for digital agencies,
and marketers and business people.
That's because baseball
took the stance a decade ago
that they would create an
organization called BAM
and they would monetize
every piece of content
thus every free piece of content
on YouTube and social media
was taken down by Major League Baseball.
Plus baseball teams
couldn't do their own stuff
nor could players.
It was all controlled at a
central level to monetize.
They made a lot of
money in the short term,
but they completely killed
the brand of the sport.
- [Male Audience Member] Along the lines
of controlling the IP,
I know that you had mentioned Nintendo
and them finally getting to the app game.
- Yes.
- If you ran Nintendo,
what would be your next
move to win that game?
- If I ran Nintendo today, I'd
probably put out 5,000 pieces
of creative content
starring Zelda and Mario
and build up the IP and make
sure all those characters
and all those visions would be winning
on TikTok, Instagram, YouTube.
You have to make sure that
Kid Icarus and Megaman
and all these things,
reboot all that nostalgia
brands, not just Mario and Zelda.
And then I would innovate for games
within the environments of streaming.
Like there's no reason that Fortnite
couldn't have been predicated
on Nintendo characters.
So look at multi-player streaming games.
And I would look at mobile
games very heavily for females
because the IP translates
extremely well to the female demo.
I would just be contemporary.
I'd probably start 10 original podcasts.
I would just produce at scale.
This has now become
singularly a making game.
Make.
Make, make, make.
(audience laughs)
- [Male Audience Member] I
think our final question we have
from one of the live
streamers, Ed from SAI digital,
is "What will be the
biggest impact 5G will make
"in digital marketing out of the gate,
"and five years ahead?"
- Ed, is it?
Ed, I'm not really sure.
The one thing that I really know about 5G.
So, I think it's funny
how people think about 5G.
Most people, if they're even aware of it,
are like, "Cool, my phone will be faster."
Meanwhile, this is a
transcending technology.
5G will be the reason that
autonomous cars become real.
Because the lag time will be zero.
5G is the reason that a
surgeon could be woken up
in Brazil tonight because she's the best
in the world at a certain surgery,
and she can VR with 5G
performing surgery on you
while you're in New Jersey.
That's amazing.
So the speed in which information
moves is so incredible.
I don't remember the exact fact,
but this is not like from four to five.
This is like from four
to 40, or four to 400.
I don't remember if it's 10X or 100X.
But it's profound.
So I think that the ability
for information to move
with no lag is what is
really going to be profound.
Things like, you know,
when you start thinking
about technology where the paint is smart.
Some of the things we talked
about with the frigerator
and things of that nature
are predicated on 5G.
Think about a world where
our pavement outside is smart
and because of 5G can speak to our car
and your car actually slightly moves
so you don't hit the puddle
going 72 on the turnpike
which mathematically would have meant
you would have lost control
enough and predicated
on where all the other
cars are positioned to you,
it avoided an accident for you.
(upbeat music)
That's crazy ass shit.
5G.
(upbeat music)